[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public vous le
savez la promesse est dans le titre
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et se mettre au service du
public vous proposez chaque soir des
clés de compréhension des mutations de
notre société avec deux grands thèmes en
90 minutes et un débat d'actu pour
commencer et puis cette décision
annoncée hier je vais être honnête avec
vous on a d'abord cru à un gag l'Arabie
Saoudite va organiser les Jeux
asiatiques d'hiver en 2029 une absurdité
écologique forcément mais
l'aboutissement d'un projet stratégique
pour le royaume jouer la carte du
tourisme préparé la pré pétrole répondre
au Qatar et à sa coupe du monde de foot
on va comprendre ce qui se cache
derrière cette nouvelle décision
choquante d'une fédération sportive
internationale et puis pour notre débat
volontairement décalé de l'actualité du
jour c'est la guerre de l'eau que je
vous propose d'analyser agriculteurs
centrale nucléaire industriel et nous
particuliers on a tous compté notre
mètre cube en France comment gérer la
pénurie combien de milliards d'euros
faudra-t-il investir pour rénover notre
réseau vieillissant notre politique de
l'eau est-elle à la hauteur de ces
enjeux réponse dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord donc cette décision qui
nous a fait tomber de la chaise hier les
Jeux asiatiques d'hiver sont attribués à
l'Arabie Saoudite Guillaume Bertrand
une compétition internationale de sports
d'hiver au milieu du désert l’idée
pourrait faire sourire si l'urgence
n'était pas plutôt à la sobriété
énergétique pourtant les Jeux asiatiques
divers se dérouleront bien en Arabie
Saoudite en 2029 pour l'aile gauche du
Sénat c'est une aberration le projet
s'est créé une ville futuriste qui va
accueillir des pistes en plein désert
des pistes de ski des pistes de
bobsleigh donc c'est c'est un non sens
écologique et puis évidemment les
questions des droits humains est posée
la ville en question trop gêna qui
n'existe donc pas encore c'est celle-ci
le prix de sa construction 500 milliards
de dollars dans cette vidéo
promotionnelle des sportifs dévale des
pistes de ski dans une atmosphère ultra
moderne quand d'autres sont à table et à
des terrasses en doudou pour rassurer
les organisateurs indiquent que dans ce
secteur montagneux du pays les
températures descendent en dessous de
zéro l'hiver à l'appui des images montre
une neige tombe abondamment pourtant
selon les relevés satellites il neige en
moyenne moins de deux jours par an alors
pourquoi les Jeux asiatiques divergent
se déroulent-ils en Arabie Saoudite la
tenue d'une telle compétition coûte cher
et les candidats pour l'accueillir sont
de plus en plus rares deux éditions ont
même dû être annulé faute de pays
organisateurs celle de 2021 et celle de
2025 Michel Savin président du groupe au
Sénat sur les grands événements sportifs
estiment qu'il faut revoir les
conditions d'attribution pour pas se
reproduire je le redis il faut changer
le cahier des charges il faut être très
clair sur ces aspects là aussi aussi
bien qu'au niveau lavez cité sur
l'aspect du travail le droit du travail
de protection au niveau du travail mais
aussi sur les aspects environnementaux
de ces grandes compétitions à l'image du
Qatar la stratégie de communication de
l'Arabie Saoudite dont l'image est
ternie par le non respect des droits de
l'homme participe par le sport le
royaume a d'ailleurs indiqué songé à une
candidature commune avec l'Égypte et la
Grèce pour accueillir la Coupe du Monde
2030 je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Sylvie mateli bonsoir vous êtes
économiste directrice adjointe de l'iris
auteur de géopolitique de l'économie
c'était aux éditions Eyrolles Agnès
Levallois bonsoir bienvenu à vous aussi
vous êtes mes 13 recherche à la
Fondation pour la recherche stratégique
j'accueille Kevin Vaissière bonsoir
bienvenue analyse en géopolitique
fondateur du site Football Club
géopolitique et puis vous publiez
mondial 22 histoires d'insolites sur la
Coupe du monde de football c'est aux
éditions max Milot Mathieu croissanto
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir victorialise
politique bienvenue à vous aussi
quelques une petite info tiens pour
commencer ce que représente les Jeux
asiatiques d'hiver c'est 47 épreuves 28
sur neige 19 sur glace est-ce que je
commence avec voyage Levallois est-ce
que vous avez comment réagi comme nous
hier quand vous avez appris cette cette
nouvelle l'Arabie Saoudite qui organise
ses épreuves on perd mon stylo oui non
mais c'est vrai que j'étais très très
étonnée et en même temps ma première
réflexion ça a été de me dire tiens
c'est la sur le Qatar avec le Qatar qui
organise cette coupe du monde et ça rend
vraiment les saouïa les émiriens
complètement fou si je peux vraiment
l'expression n'est pas exagérée à mon
sens c'est une histoire d'ego quoi ah
mais terrible c'est à dire que le plus
petit pays de la région le Qatar qui a
une certaine autonomie par rapport à
l'Arabie ce que ne supporte pas l'Arabie
qui est pure remporter cette Coupe du
Monde qui est quand même l'événement
alors je suis pas sportive et je suis
pas spécialiste mais quand même le plus
important au monde ça ça les rend fou
parce qu'ils assume que ça n'est
vraiment pas au Qatar à organiser une
telle manifestation d'ailleurs ils lui
ont vraiment mis des bâtons dans les
roues avec le blocus en 2017 les Émirats
et l'Arabie aidé en cela par l'Égypte et
donc ma première action c'est de me dire
bon c'est vrai qu'ils essayent
d'organiser beaucoup de manifestations
sportives depuis le Dakar le rallye
Dakar quand même qui maintenant se
déroule en Arabie Saoudite on l'a vu
l'hiver dernier donc on est vraiment
dans cette compétition et dans cette
rivalité de puissance régionale l'Arabie
est évidemment un pays nettement plus
important que le Qatar et qui donc par
ce biais-là montre qu'il est capable lui
aussi de pouvoir faire quelque chose et
puis pour le prince héritier évidemment
c'est aussi un affichage très très
important évidemment Mohamed Ben Salman
on va on va détailler un peu sa prise de
pouvoir ainsi vivre Martelly il y a
aussi un enjeu de diversification il y a
ce bras de fer mais il y a quand même un
vrai enjeu de diversification de
l'économie de du royaume pétrolier oui
et c'est assez paradoxal que ça se passe
avec ce symbole des Jeux olympiques
d'hiver parce que la diversification
elle est indispensable parce que la
transition énergétique est parce que les
grandes économies de la planète ont
annoncé que d'ici quelques quelques
décennies dans quelques années en
réalité elle serait neutre en carbone
donc elle ne consommerait que très peu
de pétrole et donc l'économiquement
moins dépendante de l'Arabie Saoudite
donc il faut faire cette transition
énergétique et là où pour nous ça
s'exprime en termes de sobriété en
termes de énergie renouvelable et
abondante des énergies fossiles
vraisemblablement ça a pas tout à fait
la même notion et les mêmes conséquences
pour l'Arabie Saoudite qui cherche à
identifier son économie alors à la base
en s'ouvrant plutôt au tourisme elle a
elle a assoupli sa politique de visa à
l'automne 2019 mais ouvert un site qui
est une sorte de pétrale équivalent de
pétrole mais en Arabie Saoudite
de très belles excursions et il y a de
très beaux sites à visiter en Arabie
Saoudite c'est pas on peut aller faire
du tourisme en Arabie Saoudite et c'est
vrai qu'organiser des Jeux Olympiques
même s'ils ne sont pas magnifiques
ça reste dans le l'esprit des Jeux
Olympiques bah c'est toujours ça de prix
ça fait on vous c'est diffusé sur toutes
les télés probablement essentiellement
des pays asiatiques et c'est très suivi
donc ça peut attirer ça peut attirer le
touriste effectivement vont assez peu
regarder en général les médailles d'or
aux Jeux d'hiver c'est pas trop les les
Asiatiques c'est dur à prononcer qu'il
est remporte bref je voudrais qu'on
écoute une première action celle du
ministre saoudien des sports qui se
défend des accusations de sport washing
c'est à dire de d'utiliser le sport pour
redorer le blason du royaume écoutez
nous avons entendu beaucoup de critiques
mais nous avons fait face en disant que
ces événements et ses changements qui se
produisent dans le royaume et la
transformation qui se déroule dans le
cadre de la vision 2030 est en fait un
progrès vers un meilleur avenir pour le
royaume
des Sierre le est-ce qu'on peut dire que
l'Arabie saoudite a du retard en la
matière si on compare notamment au kata
ou à d'autres pays de la région oui
Larabie saoudite a du retard de la Coupe
du Monde qui avait obtenu le Cader en
2010 c'est vrai que ça ça a créé un sans
précédent dans la région et c'est vrai
que depuis que MBS est aux commandes du
pays depuis 2015 l'Arabie saoudite a à
cœur de rattraper son retard de manière
offensive en tout cas depuis 2018 avec
l'organisation de plusieurs événements
donc on parlait effectivement du raid
Dakar mais il y a aussi un tour cycliste
qui a eu lieu l'accueil de Super Coupe
d'Espagne et d'Italie aussi sur sur le
territoire saoudien alors ça il faut
expliquer c'est le foot le sport roi et
la Supercoupe c'est quoi c'est la coupe
en gros c'est dans un championnat genre
Espagne Italie c'est le champion
d'Italie qui rencontre celui qui a gagné
la Coupe d'Italie d'Espagne et ça il le
délocalise au Qatar c'est ça en Arabie
en Arabie Saoudite en France notamment
avec cette super coupe de France qui
s'appelle le Trophée des champions qui a
été délocalisé en Israël donc c'est une
pratique qui qui devient pour aller plus
loin des clients du public
et on parlait du football et c'est vrai
que l'Arabie saoudite a beaucoup investi
dans ce domaine là et depuis
effectivement la fin du blocus avec le
Qatar et bien l'Arabie saoudite a pu
s'ouvrir les portes du football en
rachetant le club de Newcastle jusqu'à
présent c'était le Qatar qui bloquait
parce qu'il y a fait un différent avec
BeIn Sport l'Arabie Saoudite essayer de
pirater le réseau avec la fin du blocus
finalement ça a permis de d'ouvrir les
relations diplomatiques et ça a permis à
l'Arabie Saoudite d'avoir aussi son club
de football dans la prestigieuse
Première League et on voit que il
continue à mettre le paquet avec les
Jeux asiatiques d'hiver les Jeux
asiatiques en 2034 et avec l'objectif à
tout le visage toujours plus haut donc
pourquoi pas les Jeux olympiques ou la
Coupe du Monde on m'a parlé tout à
l'heure avec avec le sujet alors on
reviendra sur la stratégie des
fédérations internationales qui qui
distribue ces événements mais la
cinématique j'aurais quand même dire un
mot il y a une coïncidence de
l'actualité c'est aujourd'hui qu'on
apprend que les pays de l'OPE ont décidé
de baisser leur production avec les
conséquences qu'on peut imaginer sur le
prix de des carburants à la pompe pour
pour nous Mohamed Mel Salman il est dans
une période quand même où il a un
pouvoir renforcé notamment sur le pet
parce que la Russie qui est aussi un
pays producteur de pétrole et moins
puissant quoi c'est c'est un peu
mécanique ce qu'on est en train
d'expliquer
Arabie Saoudite a toujours dominé l'OPE
c'est vrai par contre que bah il y a une
certaine habitude au pétrole cher et que
dès que le prix du baril baisse un peu
il avait fortement augmenté au mois de
mars après la guerre la déclaration de
guerre enfin pas déclaration de guerre
le début de la guerre en Ukraine et il a
un peu laisser cet été parce que les
tensions se sont se sont lissées sur les
marchés du pétrole mais est-ce qu'il a
une sorte de pardon nous interrompre de
sentiments d'impunité fort de ce pouvoir
alors pas Mohamed pas que Mohamed Ben
Salman ça fait des années que l'Arabie
Saoudite petit pays au milieu du désert
profite largement du pouvoir que lui
octroie ses exportations de pétrole il
faut savoir qu'au mois de mars 2022 les
exportations de pétrole de l'Arabie
Saoudite du fait de l'augmentation des
prix en dépassait les 30 milliards de
dollars donc ça a été un recul en un
mois qui n'avait pas été atteint depuis
depuis 10 ans mais ça nous met aussi en
perspective les 500 milliards qui vont
être investis essentiellement dans des
infrastructures pour accueillir ces Jeux
asiatiques donc on s'aperçoit que c'est
pas un surmontable en fait comme ardoise
pour l'Arabie Saoudite la question qui
va se poser je serai curieuse de voir
mais on le verra d'ici une dizaine
d'années un petit peu moins s'ils ne
vont pas reproduire le scénario
brésilien parce qu'au fond le Brésil
avait investi fortement dans l'accueil
des Jeux Olympiques en 2016 à une
période 2010-2012 où la croissance
économique était forte ou les
investissements chinois étaient
extrêmement importants et puis le la
prospérité c'est un petit peu tari en
2016 il y avait une forte inflation et
les gens qui descendaient dans la rue en
critiquant fortement en fait ce ces Jeux
Olympiques et cette dépense cette guerre
d'argent en fait
oui effectivement ça va être intéressant
de voir à terme quel impact ça pourra on
y reviendra à ce projet Neum là cette
ville totalement dingue futuriste dans
un instant
je voudrais qu'on donc s'intéresse
maintenant à la stratégie des
fédérations quand même aussi parce que
dans ce dossier il est passionnant à
plus d'un titre et aussi pourquoi des
fédérations internationales des
fédérations sportives attribuent ces
événements on va rappeler les Jeux
olympiques d'hiver à Pékin déjà 2022 là
c'était il y a quelques mois 100% déjà
artificiels bon on peut se poser
quelques questions évidemment la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar on l'a rappelé avec
des stades ouverts climatisés bref donc
assez Joseph asiatiques d'hiver pour
l'Arabie Saoudite Agnès Levallois si on
se focus un peu sur cet événement
pourquoi ces pays asiatiques ils savent
qu'ils vont être critiqués avec une
décision comme celle-là notamment avec
les plantes transition écologique qui
sont lancés en Europe et pas seulement
dans beaucoup de pays pourquoi ce choix
quels sont les liens de des plus
puissants de ces pays avec l'Arabie
Saoudite pourquoi il décide de donner
cet événement à la réplique
d'Asie dépendent de l'Arabie Saoudite
hier c'est un pique qui est comme on
vient de le dire beaucoup beaucoup de
ressources beaucoup de richesses qui a
renforcé ces liens avec les pays
asiatiques puisque l'Arabie Saoudite ce
qui est intéressant de comprendre c'est
qu'il y a une évolution des des rapports
de force régionaux et internationaux que
l'Arabie saoudite a pris acte du fait
que l'alliance avec les États-Unis
n'était plus aussi solide qu'elle a été
à une époque et donc à partir de là MBS
lui donc le prince héritier qui est
l'homme fort du royaume a renforcé ses
liens avec tout un tas d'autres
partenaires et en particulier les
partenaires asiatiques en sachant en
plus que les pays asiatiques ne vont pas
critiquer sa stratégie parce que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux dépendent d'aide au
développement qui sont attribués par la
vie et qu'une grande partie de la
population immigrée en Arabie Saoudite
via de certains nombres de pays
asiatiques une question extrêmement
dépendante puisqu'en gros sur 30
millions d'habitants vous avez 10
millions de population immigrées alors
toute la population étrangère travaille
tous les travailleurs ne viennent pas
d'Asie mais une grande partie et ceux
qui occupent les fonctions les moins les
moins importantes et donc c'est une
population qui ne va pas râler qui ne va
pas revendiquer des droits et les pays
dont ils sont originaires encore moins
puisque c'est une manne financière qui
revient dans ces pays d'origine et donc
là il y a vraiment une relation si vous
voulez très forte entre l'Arabie
Saoudite qui d'un côté veut revoir ses
relations et veut renforcer ses
relations avec cette cette zone et des
pays qui vont pas lui renvoyer à la
figure la question droit de l'homme la
question du droit du travail ou autre
Mathieu
de ces événements sportifs il faut se
souligner enfin vous connaissez ça sur
sûrement beaucoup mieux que moi j'ai que
soit l'attribution des Coupes du Monde
l'attribution des Jeux il y a toujours
un moment on se dit mais pourquoi
pourquoi et il y a toujours des enquêtes
qui sont lancées et il y a eu par le
passé des scandales de corruption et il
y a en France une enquête qui est en
cours sur le rôle qu'aurait pu jouer la
France à un moment donné pour attribuer
par exemple la Coupe du Monde au Qatar
c'est du opacité absolue et puis ça
n'est pas guidé par des standards de
démocratie de droit humain ni
d'environnement l'Arabie Saoudite ça
devrait être le pari du monde ils ont
quand même découpé vif un journaliste
dans une ambassade en Turquie et
quelques années ils viennent de
condamner à 34 ans de prison une femme
parce qu'elle avait fait des tweets
voilà qui ça devrait être le paria du
monde démocratique et même du monde en
général c'est quand même un régime
extrêmement dur ou une dictature
religieuse une théocratie on peut
appeler ça comme on veut et voilà et
tout le monde va se retrouver en Arabie
Saoudite enfin tous les pays peut-être
un mot sur les fédérations il y a un
côté quoi État dans l'État c'est une
fédération d'abord c'est très riche
notamment la Fédération internationale
de football
elle a ses propres règles d'où l'opacité
dont parlait d'en parler Mathieu oui en
fait il y a une certaine opacité puis un
côté hégémonique notamment pour la FIFA
et le CIO ou les conditions c'est le
Comité international olympique et là
pour le coup c'est le comité asiatique
olympique qui a désigné l'Arabie
Saoudite qui était d'ailleurs le seul
pays candidat pour ces Jeux asiatiques
d'hiver et en fait se pose finalement
une double question pour l'industrie
sportive et pour ses fédérations c'est à
dire que il y a beaucoup d'États qui
viennent pour finalement utiliser cette
visibilité intellectuelle par le sport
donc le Qatar l'Arabie Saoudite la Chine
aussi et après l'autre problème c'est
que pour les les Jeux d'hiver notamment
ils ont un manque de candidature on
parlait tout à l'heure de du cas chinois
avec les Jeux olympiques d'hiver à Pékin
et finalement il y avait plusieurs
candidatures européennes et au final il
restait plus que le dossier de Pékin et
le dossier
et donc après avec les enfants
notamment la Norvège notamment où
ça coûte de plus en plus cher et souvent
ça coûte très cher à long terme au pays
qui organise quoi tout à fait et puis
après les les fédérations cherchent
aussi à voir un seul pays organisateur
mais de parler coûts et l'inflation des
coûts d'organisation ça ne cesse
d'augmenter et on voit aussi que il y a
des patchwork de co-organisation qui
sont en train de se mettre en place pour
la Coupe du monde de football 2030 là où
on a vu le cas de l'Arabie Saoudite de
l'Égypte et de et de la Grèce où on voit
pas forcément de cohérence ou parfois on
essaie aussi de donner des valeurs
symboliques au sport là il y a la ça
vient de tomber il y a l'Ukraine qui
veut organiser la Coupe du monde avec
l'Espagne et le Portugal mais finalement
est-ce que c'est le bon levier pour
défendre la cause ukrainienne que
d'utiliser le sport et de finalement
comment dire vider de nature les
compétitions sportives internationales
je voudrais revenir sur l'enjeu quand
même environnemental cinématelli le fait
que des pays asiatiques
ou trois l'organisation de ces Jeux
d'hiver à un pays comme l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est une façon de dire aux
enjeux vos enjeux de transition
écologique on s'en moque quoi alors vous
avez pollué la planète vous payez
occidentaux pays riches pendant des
décennies voire des siècles bon bah
laissez-nous faire ce qu'on veut sachant
que c'était le volontairement un peu je
suis volontairement un peu provocateur
il est clair que pour les pays
émergents les pays du Sud en général bah
ils considère que le changement
climatique c'est le problème de
l'Occident que c'est ce sont les
Occidentaux qui ont causé cette
situation et ils ont pas complètement
torturant et que c'est aux Occidentaux
de corriger sauf que même s'ils n'ont
pas complètement tort voir s'ils ont
complètement raison le changement
climatique il est là et que si tout le
monde fait pas un effort d'une manière
ou d'une autre on ne luttera pas contre
ce changement climatique et donc c'est
véritablement dramatique
la double peine on va dire climatique et
notamment le Pakistan il y a quelques il
quelques jours on est en plein dans ce
démonstration dans les négociations
internationales il y a un certain nombre
de fonds qui sont mis en place pour
accompagner la lutte contre le
changement climatique de ces pays mais
il est bien évident que ces fonds sont
abondés par les pays les plus riches qui
demandent des contreparties et bah
organiser des jeux olympiques qui peut
des Jeux asiatiques pardon je vais pas y
arriver qui plus est divers c'est pas
forcément le meilleur gage de neutralité
carbone dans les années qui viennent
évidemment beaucoup de réactions
politiques ici en France forcément alors
je vais en citer une ou simplement sur
Twitter celle de Manon Aubry pour la
France insoumise les déserts et les
montagnes d'Arabie Saoudite seront
bientôt un terrain de jeu pour les
sports d'hiver selon le Conseil
olympique d'Asie inadmissible ne perdons
pas de temps boycott interdiction pour
les entreprises de participer au projet
opposition diplomatiques et puis cet
après-midi ici au sénagu Guillaume
Gontard le président du groupe
écologiste au Sénat écoutez sa réaction
ce type d'événements de cette manière là
je ne parle pas des droits humains et de
toutes les problématiques qu'on peut
avoir avec l'Arabie l'Arabie Saoudite
mais on doit trouver d'autres lieux pour
faire ces jeux il y a des stations de
ski qui existent et peut-être réutiliser
c'est ça aussi la sobriété
Guillaume guantard au micro de Cécile
siksu la question du boycott là les elle
est évidemment évoquée par les
personnalités politiques françaises
elles se posent aussi pour la Coupe du
Monde de au Qatar c'est dans 6 semaines
vous voulez revenir sur la décision de
plusieurs mairies plusieurs
municipalités françaises de ne pas
retransmettre les matchs oui c'est
devenu la dernière tendance dans les
villes de gauche surtout un dire non
avec ses petits points ou avec ses
petits pieds plutôt à la Coupe du Monde
au Qatar en privant les concitoyens de
retransmission de match sur écran géant
alors c'est Strasbourg qui a donné le
premier coup de crampon la capitale
européenne siège de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme ne peut pas
décemment cautionner les maltraitances
alors c'est une allusion évidemment au
sort des plus de 6000 dit-on vous voyez
notamment Philippins disparus dans la
construction des stades et puis elle ne
peut fermer les yeux non plus Strasbourg
quand les droits sont ainsi bafoués
d'autant plus que cette organisation
d'une coupe du monde dans un désert et
une aberration et un désastre écologique
alors c'est un argument qui a été repris
les deux droits humains environnement
par Bordeaux l'île et même Paris et il y
aura aucun écran géant aucune Fan Zone
dans la capitale nous ne souhaitons pas
pardon relayés de façon festive cette
Coupe du Monde expliquant à l'hôpital de
ville alors on a envie de dire trembler
qatari devant ce festival de démagogie
c'est pas une bonne idée non associés à
mes yeux c'est absurde inefficace mal
ciblé incertain en termes de sécurité
publique il réaliste et même peut-être
hypocrite qui seront les plus déçus dans
cette affaire c'est des Strasbourgeois
les Lillois les parisiens ou les Qataris
je pense que qu'on connaît réponse après
un début de décennie qui a quand même
été marqué par deux trois confinement et
autant de couvre-feu un moment où les
Français ont la vie dure et le moral
dans les chaussettes les voilà privés de
ces rassemblements festifs qu'ils
affectionnent pour soutenir leur équipe
pire qu'il est privé les maires qui
prennent la décision de renvoyer chacun
chez soi sont précisément les mêmes
mères qui nous promettent
diplomatique il faut qu'il cesse de
commerce avec lui il faut que la France
cesse de lui vendre des armes ah tiens
qui fut le premier président avant des
armes au Qatar François Hollande
beaucoup de rafales présidents
socialiste tient comme Martine Aubry
Annie galgo à la tête d'un exécutif où
il y avait un gouvernement au siège des
écologistes tiens comme jeanne-marseguin
comme pierre-émique le maire de Bordeaux
le climat et le droit de l'homme sont
des vrais sujets et il faut solliciter
que les maires sont saisissent mais
alors faut le faire partout parce qu'on
se souvient pas que Martine Aubry grand
amoureuse de l'Empire du Milieu au point
d'avoir été nommé autre présentante pour
la France en Chine et eu autant de
prévention en matière d'environnement
droit humain quand elle voulait épurer
les relations diplomatiques avec Pékin
reconstruire un lien affectif avec la
Chine j'en finis avec la palme de la
contorsion pour moi qui attribué à Anne
Hidalgo sans contest un grand ami des
qatari et première supporteuses quand il
s'agit de foot sous les couleurs du PSG
au Parc des Princes à Paris la voilà qui
fait la leçon à ces mêmes amis qatari et
se pardon ses habits neufs de grande
bricoteuses en chef quand il s'agit de
foot adoa où est la cohérence au
vestiaire sans doute
Agnès Levallois est-ce que est-ce que on
peut boycotter ces événements pour c'est
quand ils sont à partir du moment où ils
sont attribués c'est trop tard est-ce
qu'il y a un moment où on peut où on
peut c'est ce que disait Manon Aubry
dans son dans son tweet c'est maintenant
qu'il faudrait faire en sorte de de
boycotter ces Jeux asiatiques
en Arabie Saoudite mais bon avec quel
levier quand on est nous ici à Paris
mais est-ce que je trouve absurde c'est
qu'effectivement cette décision a été
prise c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un comité
qui attribué la Coupe du Monde qui
attribuait maintenant ses jeux et donc
ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui et je
partage tout à fait votre analyse ça me
paraît d'une hypocrisie absolue d'autant
plus qu'on a de cesse que de commercer
et d'entretenir des relations
excellentes avec des pays de la région
vous l'avez rappelé et que Emmanuel
Macron le président français a été le
premier aller en Arabie Saoudite serrer
la main du prince héritier qui avait été
omis au banc de la communauté
internationale en raison de l'assassinat
de rachodji ce journaliste découpé en
rondelles en consulat saoudien à
Istanbul donc on est quand même dans un
dans une situation qui est complètement
aberrante soit on est cohérent
effectivement soit en boycott parce que
ces pays ne sont pas fréquentables mais
on a tellement besoin de l'Arabie
Saoudite aujourd'hui et du Qatar pour
des questions énergétiques absolument
évidentes tout le monde fait la cour au
Qatar aujourd'hui puisque c'est à des
plus grands producteurs de gaz au monde
mais je suis d'accord avec vous sur le
les enjeux diplomatiques et sur
l'hypocrisie mais sur l'aspect sur la
transition environnementale on peut pas
non plus se satisfaire de continuer de
de d'organiser des événements aussi
gigantesques et de les uns et de les
attribuer à des pays où il y a zéro
tradition au Qatar de football et en
Arabie Saoudite de de sports d'hiver
pardon on peut pas se satisfaire
que ce sont ces fédérations qui
attribuent alors moi je ne connais pas
je ne suis pas dans le secret de du
fonctionnement de ces fédérations mais
l'aberration elle est là et c'est ça qui
est mis en valeur me semble-t-il à
travers l'attribution de ces grandes
manifestations sportives mais on voit
bien qu'est-ce qui est en jeu c'est de
l'argent c'est simplement le fait que ce
sont des pays qui aujourd'hui ont
tellement d'argent qu'ils peuvent se
permettre de demander d'imposer et
d'obtenir parce que en face on laisse
complètement faire je trouve que la
question elle est vraiment là alors que
maintenant on dit ce qu'il fallait côté
peut-être mais je trouve ça absolument
absurde ce qu'il faut c'est empêcher que
des pays qui n'ont pas les ressources
nécessaires puissent candidater à ce
genre de manifestation sportive c'est là
pour moi l'aberration Kevin dessert si
on se place du côté des fédérations une
nouvelle fois c'est fédérateur
internationale il y a quand même un
alors c'est pas seulement du du cynisme
ou du business il y a enfin même si
c'est le business il y a une volonté
quoi de mondialiser le plus possible
leur sport leurs activités de toucher
des cibles qui ne touchaient pas
auparavant en attribuant ces événements
là oui c'est ça quand le cata obtenu la
Coupe du Monde en 2010 la FIFA c'est
félicité finalement que le Qatar est
cette coupe du monde parce que c'était
le premier pays arabe accueillir la
compétition et on parlait d'aberration
tout à l'heure c'est pour le CIO le
Comité international olympique il a
déclaré qu'il était même pas au courant
que l'Arabie Saoudite candidaté pour les
Jeux asiatiques divers de ce comité
asiatique olympique donc ça veut dire
que le CIO avait pas même pas pris
conscience de ce que ça pouvait
engendrer comme comme débat et c'est
vrai que pour la FIFA même pour le CIO
on a l'impression que tous ces enjeux
autour des droits humains écologiques
c'est pas encore pris en compte et qu'il
y a que l'aspect économique finalement
qui est mis en avant et c'est vrai que
le cas de l'Arabie Saoudite là c'est un
cas d'école finalement pour essayer de
changer les choses parce que maintenant
que cette courbe cette compétition a été
attribuée c'est maintenant au
fédérations nationales de pousser pour
que le CIO puisse et le Comité olympique
asiatique puisse changer les choses
parce qu'effectivement pour le Qatar on
parlait de boycott mais c'est trop tard
on arrive à deux mois de la compétition
tous les partenaires sont déjà sont déjà
là les stades sont aussi déjà fait et
finalement après aussi avec les enjeux
économiques avec le Qatar on ne peut pas
écouter cette compétition en termes de
de je trouve d'impact sur les les
mentalités c'est aussi des Astro il y a
le monde du sport ici
en Europe notamment en France est en
train de d'essayer de changer pour pour
organiser des événements moins Pol par
exemple je pense à Julien Pierre qui a
un ancien international de rugby qui a
créé une société qui s'appelle faire
plaire sur planète qui vraiment
œuvre à ça donc d'un côté on fait ses
efforts et de l'autre on nous annonce
que
l'Arabie Saoudite organise des jeux
d'hiver c'est c'est ça casse totalement
le moral de ceux qui sont en action vous
voyez ce que je veux dire mais après
c'est vrai que au niveau des comédiens
des des personnes qui sont à la tête des
grandes fédérations ou des grandes
organisations internationales sportives
et bah c'est pas là où il y a
effectivement ces initiatives ont parlé
effectivement de fédération la
Fédération Française de Football là
vient juste comment dire d'annoncer
qu'elle allait pousser au niveau de la
FIFA pour créer un fond d'indemnisation
par rapport aux travailleurs migrants et
aux familles qui ont été impactées et
les travailleurs qui sont morts par
rapport au chantier du Qatar mais la FFF
a pris cette position après des mois et
des mois que Amnesty et puisse pousser
finalement cette position et la question
qui se pose c'est est-ce que c'est une
position finalement une simple posture
où est-ce que va y avoir de
véritablement des changements après
cette Coupe du Monde de Qatar ça au vu
des positions de la FIFA et puis aussi
du CIO par rapport aux autres événements
j'en suis pas pas vraiment sûr si il y a
un autre aspect dans ces questions de
boycott c'est quand même les sponsors
sont des souvent des multinationales qui
sont très sensibles à ce qu'on appelle
la marque employeur c'est à leur image
auprès des consommateurs des
investisseurs des futurs talents à
recruter c'est pas bon pour la marque
employeur quand même d'être associé à
ces à ces événements comment elles sont
en accommodent alors clairement
clairement j'ai pas regardé les sponsors
qui c'était peut-être retirés ou qui se
faisait plus discret sur la coupe du
monde de foot au Qatar mais je pense que
vous l'avez dit c'est une question de
réputation donc c'est un arbitrage entre
le la bonne réputation que vous allez
acquérir et la publicité que vous faites
à sponsoriser un événement sportif et à
l'inverse la mauvaise publicité parce
que vous sponsorisez cet événement
sportif donc je pense que la situation
est très différente suivant les
entreprises si vous avez plutôt des
sportifs qui vous suivent
vous avez intérêt à rester si à
l'inverse c'est du grand public et du
grand public
européen ou américain qui est plus
attentif à ces à ces questions
environnementales peut-être que ça fait
mauvais genre et que vous avez intérêt
de vous en retirer
et c'est probablement sur les
entreprises que que peser le plus de
poids et le plus de pression parce que
c'est vrai que comme ça a été libre on
peut donner des leçons quand on est
exemplaire or aujourd'hui force est de
constater que en Europe comme aux
États-Unis on est en retard sur tous les
objectifs de lutte contre le changement
climatique le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables etc qu'on s'était fixés
donc on prend beaucoup d'engagement on
parle beaucoup mais ça commence à bouger
mais il y a pas grand chose qui se passe
et ça se voit ça se voit de l'étranger
ça se voit du reste du monde et
finalement on nous montre aussi du doigt
en disant oui ils sont gentils ils sont
toujours en train de critiquer mais
quand ça se passe chez eux ça les gêne
pas de la même manière sur les droits de
l'homme ou autre donc je suis pas en
train de cautionner ce qui est en train
de se passer mais il faut faire très
très attention avec les signaux qu'on
envoie par les critiques que l'on
profère alors même qu'il y a
probablement d'autres leviers pour faire
bouger les lignes on l'a dit les
entreprises qui peuvent investir
différemment sur ce type d'événements
pour assurer une moindre de moindre
émission de CO2 une moindre empreinte
environnementale il peut y avoir des
négociations et des coopérations aussi
pour aller vers quelque chose de plus de
plus de plus du plus sain je vous seront
pas le mot mais vous comprenez ce que je
veux dire etc etc donc c'est important
de d'avoir ce recul peut-être sur les
événements Agnès Levallois est-ce qu'il
y a aussi une dimension de de dans ce
bras de fer dont on parle beaucoup
depuis le début de la de la guerre en
Ukraine entre justement le bloc
occidental et un bloc asiatique ou Asie
Pacifique qui s'affirme de plus en plus
et qui veut pas forcément être dans la
logique stratégique où géostratégique de
que nous on peut avoir ici mais ça c'est
très clair c'est à dire depuis pour moi
la guerre en Ukraine et le révélateur de
toutes ces l'évolution géopolitique
géostratégique auxquelles nous assistons
avec l'émergence de puissance régionale
qui s'affirment de plus en plus et
l'Arabie Saoudite fait partie de ses
puissances régionales qui s'affirment
qui ont émergé et qui entendent mener
leur politique en fonction de leurs
intérêts et non plus de respecter ou
d'aller dans le sens de ce que leur
imposait auparavant leurs parrain et en
particulier les Américains et la phrase
que l'on entend le plus dans la région
aujourd'hui c'est que ce qui se passe en
Ukraine c'est votre guerre ça n'est pas
la nôtre on en a rien à faire
débrouillez-vous avec ça nous on a une
carte à jouer et pour l'Arabie Saoudite
encore plus que les autres pays c'est la
réhabilitation sur la scène
internationale grâce au pétrole et donc
au chantage que les Saoudiens peuvent
faire sur la question de la production
faire monter les prix ou les faire
baisser et quand jobiden l'appelle tout
au début de la guerre en Ukraine MBS en
disant ça serait bien d'augmenter la
production pour faire baisser les prix
MBS ne le prend pas au téléphone puisque
Joe Biden lors de sa campagne qui avait
dit qu'il ne voulut pas lui adresser la
parole en raison de son implication dans
la l'assassinat de rachodji aujourd'hui
MBS en faire mauvais jeu de mots et le
roi du pétrole et donc et le roi du
monde et il peut absolument faire ce
qu'il veut dire ce qu'il veut Joe Biden
a fini par lui rendre visite à lui
serrer la main le président français est
allé du cérémy et donc si vous voulez il
a il est tout-puissant et déjà que c'est
un jeune prince qui est en train de
s'installer et qui a de plus en plus de
de leviers entre les mains pour
s'affirmer comme le furent la période
pour lui est une période faste pour
justement montrer que finalement il fait
ce qu'il veut et que tout ce qu'on a dit
sur lui et bien n'a plus de raison
d'être parce que il a la carte maîtresse
entre les mains qui est la carte du
pétrole et de l'argent qu'il peut
distribuer en achetant du matériel de
l'armement ou tout autre chose et il
peut choisir du coup ses partenaires et
si maintenant il considère que des
partenaires occidentaux et bien ne sont
pas aussi fiables parce que on lui
reproche sa gestion des droits de
l'homme et qu'il a pas envie d'entendre
parler et bien les pays asiatiques ils
sont beaucoup plus confortables
travailler avec la Chine c'est beaucoup
mieux parce qu'il y aura jamais de
remise en question de la politique
concernant les droits de l'homme et donc
il y a un renversement et ça si on ne le
comprend pas et si on en tient pas
compte on va dans le mur parce que il y
a vraiment un fossé qui est en train me
semble-t-il quand même de s'élargir tous
les jours un peu plus si sans le mesure
pas ou si notre seul discours c'est
maintenant comment sauver nos marchés
parce qu'on se rend compte que c'est un
peu difficile mais si c'est pas
accompagné de quelque chose ça va nous
mettre dans une position extrêmement
délicate alors la pierre angulaire de
cette stratégie de l'Arabie Saoudite et
c'est le cas de le dire puisqu'on va
parler d'un de ce projet immobilier
totalement dingue c'est ce projet
gigantesque s'appelle NEOM alors je vous
propose une vidéo c'est une vidéo de de
lancement qui date d'il y a 5 ou 6 ans
donc cette mégapole futuriste on est
dans le nord-ouest du pays c'est une une
ville au bord de la mer Rouge j'espère
qu'on va voir ces images grandes comme
la Bretagne c'est comme ça qu'on nous
l'a décrit alors faites moi si en régie
est-ce qu'on a les images de voilà super
alors ce qui nous a marqué regardez on a
choisi ce cours extrême parce que sur
cette extrait on voit des femmes non
voilées c'est une des toutes premières
vidéos de de promotion de
Neoma je reste avec vous parce que moi
je me suis dit on va lancer cette vidéo
c'est sur le site du monde que je l'ai
retrouvé cet après-midi ça m'a ça m'a
choqué elle s'adresse d'abord au
touristes aux investisseurs étrangers à
qui elle s'adresse cette vidéo vous
investisseurs étrangers mais maintenant
le voile n'est plus obligatoire en
Arabie Saoudite la dernière fois que j'y
suis allé j'étais absent pas obligée de
porter le voile n'a jamais été
obligatoire là-bas il y a été
obligatoire mais aujourd'hui elle est
plus obligatoire pour les étrangers et
les Saoudiennes certains d'entre elles
ne portent plus la Baya et donc
n'importe pas le voir donc il y a une
évolution de ce point de vue là et c'est
ça que MBS mais en avant pour justifier
ses projets en expliquant que ça peut
s'ouvrir au tourisme le fameux site dont
vous parlez alola que j'ai visité donc
ça c'est le Petras saoudien c'est ça
magnifique et c'est vrai que ça fait
rêver et quand on est on se dit on est
dans un pays extraordinaire donc il y a
tous cette stratégie de MBS d'ouverture
et de montrer que c'est un pays comme
les autres dans lequel on peut aller
évidemment tout ça est à relativiser
sérieusement parce que l'Arabie Saoudite
est un pays avant tout autoritaire avec
un MBS qui aujourd'hui couverne tout
seul il s'est complètement à franchi du
consensus qui normalement fait la base
du fonctionnement politique de l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est-à-dire qu'il y a du club
des quelques princes qui gèrent le pays
aujourd'hui c'est terminé c'est lui tout
seul très autoritaire et donc à
l'extérieur il renvoie l'image d'un pays
qui est en train de s'ouvrir et à
l'intérieur il est encore plus
autoritaire pour bien montrer que même
si l'ouvre c'est lui qui va décider et
lui seul qui va décider des ouvertures
vous êtes théocratie tout à l'heure
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est juste
c'est un peu plus compliqué autoritaire
voilà il a mis de côté pour l'instant
les religieux parce que les religieux
c'est eux qui gérait la vie politique la
vie sociale pardon l'éducation haute il
les a mis de côté en leur donnant des
avantages ou en les mettant en prison
pour ceux qui étaient pas d'accord et
donc maintenant il gère ça avec donc
cette ouverture à l'extérieur ou
effectivement on voit les vidéos avec
des Saoudiennes sans voile nous on peut
y aller sans voile donc ça permet de
dire que c'est formidable et en même
temps ce que vous avez rappelé et ce qui
est fondamental cette jeune saoudienne
qui a pris 34 ans de prison pour un
tweet qui n'a aucun sens donc c'est ça
l'Arabie Saoudite aujourd'hui
l'extérieur on montre cette ville
futuriste avec on dépassera en avion on
se déplacera enfin un truc incroyable
qui va peut-être faire d'ailleurs parce
que ça rentre dans le cas de la
diversification économique le fameux
plan vision 2030 qui est important pour
pour MBS et j'ai juste un point pour qui
est très important mieux semble-t-il
c'est que MBS aujourd'hui est encore
soutenu par les jeunes Saoudiens qui
sont majoritaires dans le pays mais à la
clé il doit absolument créer des emplois
parce que la société saoudienne
aujourd'hui rencontre difficultés le
chômage des jeunes est extrêmement
important et MBS joue aussi sa
crédibilité et sa position de roi future
sur sa capacité à créer des emplois pour
les jeunes et c'est à travers donc tous
ces grands projets dont néon et donc
aussi l'organisation de ces Jeux
asiatiques ça rentre dans cette logique
de donner aux jeunes de quoi rêver de
leur montrer véritablement que l'Arabie
change pour continuer à avoir ce soutien
de la part des jeunes pour être sûr que
lors de la mort de son père ça sa
position ne sera pas remise en question
ça me paraît un point essentiel pour le
devenir du royaume effectivement néon
s'inscrit
quelle est la bonne la bonne
prononciation donc on a 10 projets à 500
milliards de dollars Sylvie matelli je
vous me redonniez un chiffre que vous
avez donné juste avant que l'émission
démarre moi je me suis dit c'est
gigantesque c'est une somme énorme et
l'Arabie Saoudite pourra pas le financer
toute seule qu'est-ce que ça représente
500 milliards pour ce pays ça dépend du
ça dépend du cours du pétrole mais au
cours actuel on un peu moins de deux ans
en fait de recettes d'exportation de
pétrole donc c'est pas énorme c'est pas
énorme finalement par contre c'est c'est
plus que le PIB saoudien donc ça
relativise aussi des choses tout à fait
mais ce projet vous y croyez
est-ce que c'est réaliste parce que moi
je lis je le dis c'est une ville grande
comme la Bretagne enfin vous voyez c'est
bon j'ai du mal à y croire quoi est-ce
que c'est de l'affichage est-ce que on
allait quand même vu d'autres dans ces
dans ces régions et dans ces pays et
grâce aux recettes d'exportation pétrole
donc oui on peut y croire après
effectivement ça va un peu à
contre-courant de la façon dont nous on
se projette dans l'avenir mais comme on
le dit depuis le début de cette émission
je suis pas sûr que la façon dont nous
projetions dans l'avenir correspondent à
l'aspiration du reste du monde pour les
années qui viennent en réalité moi je
pense qu'il prend un gros risque parce
que c'est vrai que ça peut sur le papier
on se dit il y a de l'argent et il y a
encore plus d'argent aujourd'hui en
raison de la crise ukrainienne donc il y
a des financier mais il y a quand même
besoin d'investisseurs pour mener à bien
ses projets et donc on a vu que les
investisseurs régulièrement ils sont
quand même un peu refroidis par le
comportement erratique de ce prince
qu'ils en entend ben va emprisonner tous
les hommes d'affaires aux rescalton à
Riad après qui va découper faire
découper un rondelles la journée donc il
y a quand même des questions la question
de la confiance quand même est une
question qui est posée vis-à-vis des
investisseurs dont il a besoin pour cela
donc il joue gros dans le sens où si ça
marche très bien si le projet n'arrive
pas à suivre exactement les étapes
peut-être qu'elles ont été conçues et
bien ça crédibilité peut quand même en
prendre donc là il joue aussi quand même
gros mais si ça marche alors là c'est
évidemment pour lui c'est formidable et
pour compléter ce que dit Agnès
Levallois il faut de la confiance pour
attirer les investisseurs il faut aussi
leur raconter une belle histoire
certains se sont amusés il y a quelques
années à expliquer qu'il allait envoyer
qu'ils allaient envoyer un homme sur
Mars ça a fonctionné et c'est assez
marrant parce que ça attiré des
investisseurs saoudiens justement et à
l'inverse on a aujourd'hui les Saoudiens
qui nous racontent une histoire
formidable sur une ville du futur ça les
investisseurs avec les limites cascées
Agnès Levallois
regardez cette autre vidéo l’arabie
Saoudite qui invite des influenceurs on
a retrouvé cette vidéo superbe c'est un
couple qui s'affiche alors c'est sans
doute c'est peut-être dans le c'est
peut-être dans le Petra saoudien dans
ton on entend parler tout à l'heure
quelques secondes parce que ça nous fait
rêver évidemment bref vous voyez c'est
la vie rêvée d'un couple d'influenceurs
en Arabie Saoudite on leur envoie
afficher leur bonheur dans ces sites
touristiques nous vanter les mérites du
royaume pour certains d'entre eux disent
ça ils ont bien changé quand même le
tout sponsorisé par l'Office du Tourisme
saoudien Riad nouveau Dubaï on a quand
même un petit peu de de mal à se
projeter je voudrais qu'on vienne sur la
question du soft power Kevin vessia
parce que moi je vois une contradiction
il y a ça il y a l'argent qu'on peut
dépenser en invitant des influenceurs il
y a l'argent qu'on peut dépenser pour
organiser des événements sportifs et
puis il y a la mauvaise image et je
reviens à la question de la transition
écologique parce que ça ça fait partie
de mes dadas que ces que ces événements
véhiculent vous voyez ce que je veux
dire donc moi j'ai des doutes sur
l'impact en termes de d'influence sur
les populations occidentales avec ces
injonctions ou ces messages
contradictoires après ce qui peut être
visé aussi avec l'organisation de ses
compétitions internationales là pour le
cas des Jeux asiatiques d'hiver et
finalement c'est pas le public
occidental c'est plus la population
asiatique et puis comme ça a été rappelé
c'est aussi la population saoudienne
pour montrer qu'ils peuvent avoir plus
tard accès aux loisirs des Occidentaux
c'était aussi le la stratégie de la
Chine avec les Jeux olympiques d'hiver
avec la création ça engendrer la
création de nombreux stations de ski
pour montrer à cette question moyenne
chinoise qui commençait à gagner en
termes de revenus qu'il pouvait accéder
à ses loisirs là après c'est vrai que
comme ça a été dit pour pour MBS et la
stratégie saoudienne de soft power par
le sport il y a aussi des initiatives
qui sont mises en place par rapport aux
femmes notamment il y a une compétition
de golf qui était organisée en Arabie
Saoudite avec les femmes qui avaient pas
forcément de voile et aussi en football
il y a des initiatives qui sont prises
mais c'est un petit peu de poids de
mesure parce qu'après il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire pour que les
droits des femmes évoluent là-bas et
c'est vrai que voilà cette cette
position affichée au niveau de au niveau
de ce que voudrait être l'Arabie
Saoudite et après dans les actes ce qui
se passe sur le terrain c'est toujours
cette position qui peut-être affaibli
aussi l'Arabie Saoudite par rapport aux
investisseurs pour essayer de séduire à
l'international et c'est vrai que des
projets comme Neum ou ça a été évoqué
avec ses influenceurs et aussi il y a
désormais Léo Messi aussi qui est
ambassadeur de l'Arabie Saoudite depuis
le mai de cette année totalement pour
promouvoir aussi la ville culturelle de
Jeddah à l'international il voit qu'ils
essayent aussi de faire des liens avec
des sportifs pour essayer aussi
d'adoucir cette image même si la
politique d'embès et la gestion du pays
est très autoritaire comme ça a été
rappelé ça veut dire que les qatari qui
sont les employeurs
comme on l'a rappelé effectivement les
rapports même si effectivement le Qatar
et l'arbustes sont toujours rivaux les
rapports se sont quand même beaucoup
distendu depuis et finalement cette
Coupe du monde ça peut être veut être
utilisé comme un vecteur pour glorifier
tout le Golf Persique c'est pour ça
notamment que il y a de plus de
partenariats qui sont mis notamment pour
le déplacement des supporters le Qatar
pourra pas accueillir tous les
supporters sur la zone donc il y a
plusieurs hôtels qui seront aux Émirats
arbres Unis en Arabie Saoudite qui
pourront faire des transferts de
supporters et ainsi que ça puisse
prendre nous voir toute la région alors
ça aussi l'impact écologique on peut en
parler parce que les navettes d'avion
entre les pays voisins et le Qatar pour
assister au match et si on va se poser
aussi à la Coupe du Monde 2026 qui sera
Canada Etats-Unis Mexique peut revenir
peut-être il faut arrêter les grands
événements sportifs qui nous font rêver
devant notre télé bref ça c'est un autre
débat j'aurais terminé sur la
personnalité et ce sentiment d'impunité
de Mohamed Ben Salman MBS
à propos de l'assassinat du journaliste
Jamal kasogui il vient de se faire
nommer premier ministre Mohamed Ben
Salman et vous avez forcément vu que ces
avocats disent qu'il y a il y a une
logique de quoi d'immunité contre les
tribunaux américains c'est un peu sur ce
sur quoi émise alors d'abord c'est
exceptionnel parce que normalement c'est
le roi qui est premier ministre et lui
était donc vice premier ministre et donc
le roi donc son père a signé ce décret
et qui va à l'encontre de la loi
saoudienne qui normalement ne permet pas
ça et effectivement donc il a été dit
que il y avait cet élément qui était à
la clé pour le permettre de se protéger
puisque il y a un certain nombre
d'Américains qui sont encore quand même
très choqués parce qu'il s'est passé
tout le monde n'a pas oublié cet épisode
même si on a tendance à ne plus en
parler autant qu'auparavant et donc ça
peut être un moyen effectivement pour
pour MBS de se protéger certains ont vu
dans cette nomination qui date de la
semaine dernière on sait que le roi est
pas dans très bonne santé est-ce que
c'est un moyen de commencer à préparer
les esprits pour dire que le roi est
encore un peu plus malade qu'il ne
l'était enfin voilà donc il y a beaucoup
de de bruit autour de ça mais ce que ça
veut dire en tous les cas c'est que le
roi mis tout ce qui peut dans la balance
aujourd'hui pour être sûr que son fils
sera le prochain roi et qu'il n'y aura
pas de contestation possible lorsqu'il
disparaîtra parce que là il bénéficie
encore vraiment le soutien de son père
qui veut absolument tout faire pour lui
passer le flambeau merci à tous merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat qui était vraiment passionnant à
bientôt sur Public Sénat